this is Angie County the weather is
Pleasant there's no traffic or pollution
and the aroma of surrounding tea Farms
fills the air
most of the young people staying at this
shared living space are Urban Youth
house do not start your life in a city
where you can't even have a life or
where you can't even survive you can go
to tier 2 or tier 3 cities or even small
companies it's all okay
one of the reasons he came here is the
increasing difficulty of finding a job
youth unemployment has officially soared
to a record high of more than 20 percent
most of the young people here are doing
freelance remote work and they say they
don't have to worry about the stress of
competing for limited full-time jobs
because their daily expenses here are
low here every day I spent about 70
cents on food and I'm quite happy around
12 million young people are set to enter
the workforce this year
one thing that if you look at this
recent statistics that the record number
of universe University equatori going
after master degree or PhD degree so I
mean the the real challenge might be
even after two or three years of all
these graduates coming out from the
master program
so far Angie county has enticed more
than 600 Urban Youth to relocate late
last year president Xi Jinping called on
young people to help Revitalize the
Countryside by finding work in rural
areas local authorities in anti-county
are actively promoting this idea trying
to incentivize thousands of urban youth
to move here the local government here
has spent more than 14 million dollars
on infrastructure to meet the needs of
its new residents
we try our best to lower their costs to
run startups and offer support for food
residents and travel we have also built
some shared dining rooms and apartments
and facilities for daily life like cafes
bakeries and barbecues things that young
people like the government has also
supported projects like co-living spaces
for so-called digital nomads
from our individual ability we can't
change the whole society or environment
but we can gather together to change our
own small environment
the rural push won't solve the growing
youth unemployment crisis and it's not
intended to be a solution for everybody
but for some young people it buys them
time to consider their uncertain future
without the knowing pressure of City
Life Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Angie
County China